[Music]
I create kind of what you hear on
television so I get music like it sound
effects I get Foley's I get ADR dialogue
all sorts of things and it's my job to
kind of mix them together and make them
make it sound like all have to do their
best to enjoy the daily downpour I've
been working within that twister unit
for a long time I worked on planet Earth
warned blue planet before that so I've
known a lot of the producers through the
years when their assistant producers and
researchers and things like that so I've
kind of been involved with we were kind
of talking about it for quite a few
years before it happens so it's kind of
a project that I'd heard about for a
long time it wasn't called planet Earth
- it was called our planet for a while
it was kind of you know it was
potentially could be plenty earth too
but it had to kind of prove itself
before it was allowed to have that title
it's as if the trees breathe out cards
they gather over the forest until
finally
a burst other things with natural
history is that we are we're trying to
create what you think you should here
but I'd say 99% of the time it's shot
Butte a lot of things a shot off speed
these very long lenses they use various
devices to give lovely tracking shots
things helicopters they use drones all
sorts of stuff and all those things
aren't very good for sound because you
don't hear them a lot more than you do
the animal or whatever it is this long
way away so we spend a lot of time
trying to recreate what you would hear
if you were there so it's very similar
to drama in that respect is its kind of
a bit different to normal documentary
where you start with sound that's been
recorded people talking and you add
things to it natural history you tend to
start with nothing there are sixteen
males in this bachelor do the anthem
must evict every single one of them from
his territory
this next sequence is the langur monkeys
it's amazing backdrop in all the bright
blue and everything and they'd shot a
lot of it off speed so it was a really
good sound design sequence for us this
he has chased half the bachelors away
but a splinter group was looped back and
is harassing his females mmm there we go
there's that call there which is you
know it's doing such a specific Nori's
that we had to get the right one and
then there's this shot here where it
goes really really slow motion and that
was kind of the key to actually let's
let's let's change this here and that's
going to make the sounds fit in with the
music a lot lucky to have the really
good temp score from the composer's here
so I could work with that and fit all
the sounds ins when they bang off the
railings there and those kind of things
that can really make it fit in with the
music
[Music]
finally he manages to expel them all in
the in the different programs in the
series there are there are lots of
different habitats different styles we
had a lot of time to talk with the
producers before we started on each show
which was great so we we spent a lot
time going through the fine cuts or even
before their fine cuts and working out
the style of the sequences whether it's
going to be a big dramatic sequence was
it quieter we being tender here do we
want to you know do want this to be
scary and oppressive or to be honored to
be really nice and kind of relaxed and I
think one of the things that the series
did really well was to get that journey
through all the sequences working really
well they thought very hard about not
having lots and lots and lots of action
sequences next to each other it kind of
flows you through that through the story
cities Freddy was the producer that one
and he you know we probably had the
longest spotting session of the lot with
it with him because he had very very
good ideas about how to have to cover
each sequence and some of them we wanted
to be kind of a bit edgy and a bit
uncomfortable and almost slightly kind
of misleading the audience and making
them a bit you know on edge and other
ones we just wanted to be kind of Moody
and actually not have very much standing
there at all kind of just a contrast a
sequence it's a gun before
leopards have attacked almost 200 people
here in the last 25 years
Freddie was really keen to make this
sequence quite edgy it's um it's an
environment that people are familiar
with it's just outside a big city but
actually it's it's so spooky because
there's this massive leopard but humans
are not their usual prey these leopards
are on the hunt for something else
there's a lot of just kind of normal
City sound it's just you know some very
every day but then there's this then
there's this massive creature there and
it's kind of setup so you're not quite
sure what it's after and we we worked
quite hard on this to get the commentary
in the spacing right so that it doesn't
mislead you but you're you're not sure
and you see the leopards and you you see
them and then you see these people
walking through and you're just thinking
are they is it going to be after them
and it's not for quite a while that
David then actually says pigs and you
realize oh right
phew it's not going to be something
horrible without to watch
the Pink's keep their family close we
kind of wanted to keep it quite quiet
and quite set back so that you almost
are feeling their motion yourself rather
than having to force it with the sound
so you had lots of lots of lots of
noises of the city start with and as a
sequence goes on we kind of just thinned
it out made it made it simpler and
simpler we're here just at the moment
where the pigs are all sleeping and
they're very calm and you just kind of
fill with this sense of dread of what's
gonna happen
[Music]
and then when it does it's even more
horrible you think this little piglet
squeals and honestly some of the sounds
that are in there were just far too grim
to use the leopard grabs the squealing
pig and runs through and then de the
orchestra goes for the sound goes full
and it's you know it's a massive
dramatic moment I think having that
dynamic range between the quiet stuff
beforehand and the really exciting
loud bit after kind of really really
help that sequence as a big series it's
got to have a style that runs through
all of it so it was great for me being
involved in all of the programs I could
make sure that the same kind of ideas
done and sometimes I do some of the same
techniques going between sequences or
the same style and I believe in having a
lot of space in films because you've got
something really amazing the last thing
you want is somebody telling you lots
and lots and lots of information so I'm
you know quite well known and production
team for just sitting there going I
don't want to hear that don't not
interested in that fact I know it's an
amazing fact but actually if people are
interested they can look that up what I
like doing is you know setting something
up it's it's amazing the footage they've
got and I think that the tendency can be
try to over inform you during those
sequences I'm very much like no no no
let's not say that let's just watch
everybody is going to be so mesmerised
by the sequence that it's in it's better
just to leave it in anyone
[Music]
I think the racist makes is a really
good example whereby there was in that
sequence quite a lot of commentary tell
me things about those snakes but
actually enlisted with the producer that
one she was she was you know with me
very much in like let's let's just let
the audience watch it because people are
going to be sitting there going oh my
you know it's edge of the seat stuff and
knowing you know lots of facts about the
snakes and the big Yanis is not
necessarily going to help the drama the
sequence and actually you know this
these these kind of shows they cross the
boundary between drama and they out
there are documentary they're telling
you information they're showing you
things but it's in a very cinematic and
amortized way so you've got to kind of
just tread that line between
[Music]
a near miraculous escape quite often in
the business it's it's amazing how
little communication happens during the
making of a program people kind of all
know what their jobs are and they kind
of turn up and get on with it and you
can make very satisfactory programs
doing it that way but when you get to
that extra layer of communication
between all the people involved in the
production it really helps and it means
that you're all setting off on the same
path and heading towards the same goals
in working as a team there are the guys
feeding me the sound track lace so that
was Kate's Hopkins and Tim Owens and the
Foley crew we've got a great great guy
who does phonies could Richard Hinton
who he lives in that rather strange
world where everything makes a noise and
everywhere he goes he's looking at
things and thinking all that I make a
good sound of gathering props and
collecting random bits of bits of stuff
that most people would just throw away
anything oh now I'll use that I've never
seen a pair of size-12 high heels before
I'll have those when I'm doing a drama
one thing that really helped on the
series is the musicians were feeding me
temp mixes of the music so as soon as I
started working on the programs I had a
very good idea where the music was going
I've got the sound in front of me I've
got a very good guide commentary so I
kind of know where everything's going to
fit so even from an early mixing stage I
can kind of put pieces in the right
place and think about moving things
around and there's an awful lot of
tuning of sound effects moving of sound
effects and just tweaking them a little
bit just to make them fit in with the
music at the right places
the composers were great because they
were very much aware of the music being
a part of the sequences and in some
places it was driving the sequence in
some place it would be supporting the
sequences and we've got David telling
stories and tales you know giving this
really vital information at times as
well so kind of fitting them all
together can sometimes be a bit of a
jigsaw that
you
this is Thomas r2
you
[Music]